okay so there is a new poll released
yesterday which shows Bernie Sanders
ahead of President Donald Trump by 9
percentage points in a hypothetical 2020
matchup and Joe Biden ahead of Trump by
10 percentage points in a similar
hypothetical 2020 matchup this if even
slightly accurate is incredible but
we've got some caveats the first caveat
which will be very clear to many in our
audience is that a Fox News poll is the
source of this information and I know
that that will immediately make many
people on the Left not trust it the
funny thing is that very same fact that
it is a Fox News poll is making a lot of
the American right-wing very nervous
because they tend to trust Fox News and
they're now stuck in a cognitively
dissonant spot between a rock and a hard
place so to speak the truth is that
every one of these polls has a margin of
error and the Fox News poll is not
drastically out of line with what other
polls are finding although yes the leads
the deficits that Donald Trump has
according to this latest poll are bigger
than in most other polls you have to
remember that at this point there are
also lots of undecided so the plus 10
that Biden has and the plus 9 that
Bernie has a lot of that is because
there are people who have not yet
decided many of whom many of whom will
eventually break for the incumbent so if
anybody thinks that Donald Trump is
going to lose the popular vote by 10
percentage points in November of 2020
that is extraordinarily unlikely to
happen and remember that we are still
500 days from the election and these are
only hypothetical matchups because we
don't actually know who is going to be
running against Donald Trump as the
winner of the Democratic primary this
will all start to get more
representative of what we can expect in
November of 2020 once the Democratic
debates begin once all of those one and
two percenters start to drop out and
that support starts to shift to other
Democratic candidates when Trump starts
campaigning there's a lot here that is
going to happen soon and I want to
mention something else that's funny
along these lines
I saw a discussion on a subreddit I'm
not even going to tell you which
read it because I don't want to give it
any publicity this poll showing Trump
down so big Lee to Biden and to Bernie
Sanders it sort of pierced the echo
chamber because when it came out they
came up with an amazing post hoc
rationalization I want to try to explain
it clearly because I really want you to
understand what it is that they are
trying to say in response to this poll
it's just so wacky the reaction was Fox
News faked the poll results because Fox
News wants Biden to win and the reason
Fox News wants Biden to win is that Fox
News is right-wing they want war with
Iran Trump now says he doesn't want war
with Iran Joe Biden will go to war with
Iran
so now the pro-war right-wing propaganda
apparatus wants Biden to defeat Trump so
that Biden will take us to a big war
with Iran which is why Fox News has
decided to turn on trump and publish
fake polls that show Biden winning now
aside from the fact that that entire
conspiracy theory is not based in any
fact there's another thing here which is
that it's not clear to me that polls
showing someone is winning when they're
not winning help them to win in other
words if you don't want Biden to win and
you see a poll saying he'd defeat Trump
doesn't that make you more likely to go
and support Trump so that the poll
doesn't become a reality like maybe I
don't even understand how fake polling
is designed to work but on every level
that post hoc rationalization makes no
sense what's clear is that as of right
now Donald Trump does have a problem how
big of a problem it is we won't know
until the debate start and until Donald
Trump starts actually campaigning in
earnest